it won't even weird when I was talking
to the captain when we were on the boat
like what's a captain yeah dope name
with our boy yeah boy poster um he was
like we were talking about comedy and he
was saying like in France and French is
there any French listeners correct this
man if he's just crazy and living on a
boat what he was saying that comedians
are like the concept of that is a little
different in France whereas like
comedians here like we like you know we
come up with stuff and like I don't know
we either want to make a point or it
might be edgy or we might want to
challenge something and he'd seem to be
describing comedians as more just purely
like performative so it's like it's not
really about your opinion it's about
just being funny yeah it's like it's
like what's okay yeah and he was like
you could literally never discuss
pedophilia yeah you can't even make it's
not even like this yeah like you could
never go to your agent do the pedophilia
bit like no that's out brother so what
about a balloon you have already good
with balloons
can you tie balloons that's what you're
just I believe that's way better
that's way funnier yeah it's like I can
do it in like a dick shape no no no dog
works I could do it a baby shape and
then kiss it that works yeah is it a
kiss the baby he's the baby
he's it this is the busy baby is away
the babies away kiss is a baby kiss it
master bring it into baby so I can teach
them on the forehead [ __ ] that's good
yeah the half-marathon was good jumping
around and segways do it sags day I do
I thought it
funny like when you run a race like
there's a safe one right there what
SAG's did what yeah I was up at [ __ ]
what's-her-name's place yeah yeah this
SIG yeah I was sig we fugged we had sags
careful now
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah she yeah she got that honored dude
it's uh that bit for you is like
swimming out into open water yeah yeah I
know all right coat hey Cody
just stay near the boat yeah and then
she [ __ ] got down on her no no no no
no no Cody cuz she gave me hag she got
down on her no no no stop it stop it
stop it stop it no more no no no um the
half marathon was B I was sig sig yeah I
saw somebody ragged rag the half
marathon stop yeah no it was good it was
like it's it's funny when you run a race
like that because what happens is that
like people's like tons of people go on
the streets yeah and like hold up signs
encouraging you supposed to encourage
you but now over the years so many
marathons have been done and so many
people [ __ ] do marathons now that this
sign
everyone have everyone that holds a sign
I started like competing with each other
and who can do the funnier sign hmm so
it ends up not being encouraging at all
and just is basically a competition for
attention for the people standing on the
side not doing anything right a little
it's really funny so like one of them
was just one of the way I thought was
kind of funny was don't [ __ ] your pants
like just that to to to the people that
are like most close to [ __ ] their
pants in the city at that point you know
saying another one another one which I
thought was hilarious was this girl was
holding a sign that said you think this
race is hard try dating me no I was like
this is hilarious not because you not
because of your joke that you were
trying
to make but it's hilarious in the fact
that you don't realize how much this
proves your sign
yeah in fact thank you somehow made him
a marathon about you oh you you know
saying you think this marathon is hard
try dating me yeah like absolutely not I
know right away that would be a [ __ ]
nightmare and that was not funny at all
did you love it when people like I'm
crazy yeah yeah most men can't handle me
I'm a real woman because you guys are
his or her boyfriend like running and
seeing that he's like mile [ __ ] 20
just hitting the wall out of [ __ ]
calories no electrolytes left he sees
that sign and she's like I know
yeah he just shits himself he just
stands looks at her and just [ __ ]
takes off his [ __ ] yeah diaper runner
shorts and just just suffocates himself
on the track jams them in his mouth and
just shit's everywhere he just lays on
the ground hoping he gets trampled yeah
you know speaking of it's like those
people all those people want to see when
running a race like that is like a sign
with like a hamburger on it or like a
picture of a hamburger or something
yeah something that encourages you to
keep going write these jokes don't
[ __ ] do anything I'm just one of them
was one of them was a sign says I
trained for years to hold this sign
uh-huh like the only people that find
that funny are the people across the
street with another sign that are trying
to be funny I said I trained harder than
that guy yeah exactly it's like [ __ ] all
of you man we should stand there with a
sign that says kiss our kids just hire
like a 12 year old actor for like four
hours
kiss my son he's just like wait what why
kiss my [ __ ] oh dude oh I just had a
dark thought what
close is that doesn't well these are
doesn't well these are gusting OH
[Music]